saffron I understand with the film and I
don't want to give too many spoilers
away this might for some people watching
so viewer beware but you had your own
family situations within the film how
soon did these situations happen when
you began the documentary and your
choice to weave them in the story well
about halfway through filming the
documentary my sister was diagnosed with
cancer when we started filming my
grandfather had cancer and i was going
to focus on that story line because my
sisters were the ones that started the
program because they were inspired by my
grandparents so i wanted to keep that
story in and how you know the internet
has helped my family stay in touch and
stay close so when my sister was
diagnosed it was like what do we do now
do we keep filming and there was a
period where we kind of thought you know
we're not gonna film that we're not
gonna put that in the film but um it's
strange what happens when you don't know
how you're gonna deal with the crisis
like that it kind of becomes your new
normal it was like I wasn't filming when
we were all crying or when something
really devastating was happening but I
was at the hospital with her every day
we'd all take turns going to the
hospital and she'd pick up her phone and
skype my grandparents you know because
they wanted to see her and see how she
was doing and that was our life at the
time so I would just I filmed a bit of
it and it ended up in the film and I'm
really happy that I have that footage
because it was really interesting the
way the internet helped my sister and my
grandfather stayed close they're both
going through cancer treatment at the
same time the internet allowed them to
kind of check up on one another and it
was this weird bond that they shared but
it was a really kind of sweet
relationship that develops yeah the film
definitely shows that and and your
sister is doing well today yeah calling
very well she's in complete remission
she's off at NYU studying son Wow
congratulations you know well my hats
off to you to show that in the film
because I'm sure probably it was
difficult but maybe in some ways you
looked at it almost from a new
perspective because it was like you're
filming and sometimes you're removed you
know you're more the just this viewer
but yeah did you have to really discuss
amongst your family should we include
this or was it just like this is part of
our lives and we're going to show it
there was no hesitation yeah there was
discussion about it and there's actually
not a ton of footage of that it's it's
woven throughout that story but it's not
a huge part of the story because i
didn't spend hours and hours of filming
it there was just a few moments where i
was kind of like this is a really cute
moment i might as well grab it and put
it on camera and I'm glad I did and some
of those scenes still make us choked up
and cry even I've seen the film like 200
times no nose and I see so the film's a
tweet like the scenes between my sister
my grandfather it still gets me choked
up but again i'm glad that i have that
and i think my entire family really
actually enjoys seeing it
you